la droite a toujours été une grande
formation politique dédiée à
l'environnement et je regrette beaucoup
que le fait que nous ne soyons plus en
capacité en responsabilité on n'a plus
pu continuer à faire nos preuves à leur
métier mais toutes les grandes lois
environnementales
c'est jacques chirac c'est michel
barnier c'est nicolas sarkozy c'est
nathalie kosciusko morizet on a eu de
grands ministres et de grands présidents
en la matière
et
je dois dire que en matière de
prise en compte de politique en faveur
de l'environnement on a assisté ces
dernières années à vraiment des mesures
et des décisions qui ont été erratiques
prenant l'exemple de l'énergie l'énergie
sous le précédent quinquennat emmanuel
macron a annoncé la quasi extinction du
nucléaire une de ses premières mesures a
été la fermeture de fessenheim
aujourd'hui on a plus de dix réacteurs
qui sont en panne bref la grande filière
industrielle de production d'énergie
nucléaire est en panne et aujourd'hui
alors que nous avons tant besoin
d'énergie quel drame que
l'affaiblissement de la filière du
nucléaire
quel drame que l'affaiblissement ddf à
un moment où on aurait besoin qu'edf
monte en puissance sur les énergies
et puis
les énergies alternatives
nous nous avons demandé un moratoire sur
l'éolien va partout en france on saccage
nos paysages on dresse les populations
les unes contre les autres celles qui
accueillent éolien et celles qui le
refusent
voilà donc
il ya là un enjeu majeur alors moi je
dirais que quelle est la position de la
droite qu'est la philosophie la droite
en matière de d'environnement d'abord
c'est de dire ce n'est pas dans la
décroissance que nous trouverons les
ressorts de la préservation de
l'environnement ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut continuer à consommer n'importe
comment et produire pour consommer pour
jeter évidemment non ça veut dire qu'il
faut continuer à lutter contre le
gaspillage alimentaire ça veut dire
qu'il faut respecter nos producteurs ça
veut dire que faut travailler avec eux à
une production plus respectueuse de
l'environnement ils le font ils le font
quand je vois
les efforts que font les agriculteurs
pour diminuer les produits
phytosanitaires
moi je les éradiquer de ma commune il ya
quinze ans plus de produits sanitaires
dans la commune c'est possible donc il
ya tout un tas de mesures qui peuvent
être faites
donc
la décroissance n'est pas la réponse moi
je crois au contraire à une économie
verte créatrice d'emplois et créatrice
de richesse économique je crois aussi
beaucoup en la science
vous voyez récemment on a parlé de la
réduction de dudu
du trou dans la couche d'ozone ce sont
des chercheurs qui ont théorisé ça et
qui ont montré l'influencé des gaz cfc
sur le trou dans la couche d'ozone et ce
taux est en train de se refermer parce
que les scientifiques ont montré que si
on supprime l émission des gaz
qui détruisent la couche d'ozone et bien
on allait restaurer la couche d'ozone
qui est une qui est peut-être crise donc
je crois beaucoup en la science on a
obtenu une petite victoire
conséquente qui est pas une petite
victoire mais elle est passée un peu
sous les radars médiatiques c'est
dommage nous ont demandé l'instauration
d'une taxe carbone aux frontières de
sorte que on importe pas des produits
qu'ils soient moins exigeants sur le
plan du respect de l'environnement que
ce qu'on exige de nos propres
producteurs pour protéger nos
entreprises puis pour protéger nos
consommateurs réellement et bien grasses
ou huit députés européens que nous avons
eh bien on a pu voter une taxe carbone
aux frontières pour se protéger de
produits qui ne respectent pas au mois
pour les taxer pour pouvoir affecter ces
ressources supplémentaires à la
protection de l'environnement c'est une
sacrée victoire ça s'est joué à onze
voix et on en a apporté 8 dont vous
voyez la droite la droite a des choses à
dire en matière d'environnement qui sont
très nettement différentes voire
opposées à celles du gouvernement est un
sel bien sûr d'eux
des décroissants de tous bords